c'est ici dans les hauteurs de la
possession que corinne accueillons deux
familiales vie avec trois nouvelles
personnes chez elles
trois personnes porteuses d'un handicap
dont deux en fauteuil roulant et je
ville fait partie de ces accueilli comme
en trouve un dans cette grande maison
toute une partie réservée aux hôtes
trois chambres totalement équipées
indépendante et en espace pour la
détente devant la télévision tout
simplement dans le salon pour une petite
discussion placer leur coin télé
après les trois chambres séparées ya
trois chambres avec kadhafi
la demande d'agrément pour moi ça
chauffe et ça a été assez simple mais
c'est surtout après accueillir les gens
parce que quand on accueille les gens on
accueille aussi lui a passé qu'on
accueille aussi des leur handicap et
août
il faut vraiment que client un film
aussi peut pas accueillir les gens si
y'a pas que céline quand je t'ai pas
voilà s'il faut que l'on s'entende bien
il faut que ok un truc qui se passe et
pour que tout se passe bien après qu'ils
aient que tout se passe dans l'harmonie
un espace qui permet aux accueilli de
recevoir leur famille c'est d'ailleurs
dans ce but corine aménager sa maison
pour devenir accueillant familial ses
enfants et elle vivent à l'état ce qui
permet à chacun de conserver une
certaine intimité
à part cela toutes les personnes qui
vivent dans le foyer forme une grande
famille vivent une vie sociale et vie
familiale et puis c
et leur donner un peu de bonheur de
votre vie les filles normales son mari
et son remplaçant car pour devenir
accueillant familial il faut une
continuité d'accueil pendant sa première
fois que je vis avec des handicapés
pendant sept ans j'ai bien dit oh comme
c'est les ongles c'est comme moi c'est
vraiment votre n'est pas différent
savoir qu'ils soient justement porteuses
d'un handicap ça vous dérange pas du
moment ce qu'on dérange pas il faut faut
aimer puis france a un peu gâché la main
sinon on ferait confiance mutuelle pour
exercer ce métier corinne et
d'accompagner par l'action de santé du
département puisque c'est le conseil
départemental qui délivre les agréments
elle suit également des formations
obligatoires il ya des formations qui
nous aident à mieux comprendre si les
rennais en difficulté à mieux les
aborder à comprendre leur audika c'est à
dire que ça représente comment gérer au
quotidien
s'il ya des formations qui ce fait après
c'est en fonction de ce qu'on a demandé
d'informations
c'est dans ce cadre paisible et dans une
vraie chaleur familiale que riz l'huile
apprécié chaque moment de sa vie au
quotidien et aujourd'hui lui tarde que
l'heure du déjeuner arrive car dans la
cuisine en bois ou le feu crépite
au menu rougail boucaniers hikari
pipangaï un vrai régal